I will say though people really want you
to run for political office would you
ever do that no because I feel like
that's a big responsibility cardi B you
might not want to run for political
office but she's certainly getting
involved beer bloggers here youtubers
get influences we have the power to
influence our youth to get educated when
it comes to our in a new video she's
encouraging fans to get educated we get
distracted with people putting black so
instead of posting the little post on
Twitter
why don't we post every single day these
positive things that these Democratic
these Democratic candidates want to do
for our country like this man has a big
chance of winning in 2020 and we could
change that cardi also sat down with
Bernie Sanders a candidate she's long
endorsed to film a campaign video
she wrote under this shot not me us
Thank You senator Bernie Sanders for
sitting with me and sharing their plans
on how you will change this country she
also reveals that she had him answer
questions several of her followers
submitted oh snap snap snap
Bernie also posted a pic writing in part
cardi B is right together will get
millions of young people involved in the
political process and transform this
country the best parts they met at a
nail salon
earlier this year cardi got candid about
politics with et I feel like I will be a
democratic no I'm saying the house is
full of Republicans right now it's just
like so I don't want to promise somebody
something and then it won't happen
because people are not gonna vote for
what I want or like certain things won't
happen like for example I want free
health care and I feel like college
education should be free that's how I
feel that's what I want I can promise
that because I don't know if sure there
were a lot of sad beador
[Music]
[Applause]